có quan có lý kạm hoạc của gia đình LHBNPB đã chình khai mấy mốt máy bài trực thân,
nề vận chuyển hàng tối trở đến các cộng đồng bị cô lập,
sau trận lũ lũi em trọng tại Đạo Suma Trà.
Hó đồng cứu trở đu đề mạnh khi mưa gió mùa kéo sản xin một tôn,
gây ngập xong yêu khu vực, làm giám bản xó thông và kế thành hình hủ rân,
zơi vào tình trạng kéo lương thượng và như yêu phẩm.
Cái tình ở sê nơi chủ điều thải nặng nế nhắc,
chính quyền đã bắt bố tình trạng thân cấp trong mười mũ này,
để tăng công tắc sơ tảm, phần phổi hộ cân,
và huy đặc lực lượng lên ngành,
như tuyệt đừng chính liệu hàng hoặc chạm hoàn toàn,
khiến chức thăng trở thành tương tiện tiếp tế chủ lực,
nơi ra tập trung tại cái điểm đáp để nhận hàng gủ trở từ trên không.
Cũng theo sử liệu báo cáo,
Suma diện mạnh xó lũ và lần đất đã lên tới 8,5 lệ bán lời,
hôm một chăm lời có mất tích và hơn 5,5 lệ bị thương,
nơi lũ tích đừng giúp chạm cho khi lực lượng có vọng,
nỗ lực tiếp cạnh của bật con bị chế khách,
nhằm hàng chế thêm thị thải và ổn định đời sống người dân.